in the trump era tax cuts deregulation
and low
interest rates made the rich richer much
much richer everyone else not so much
the net effect of his economic policies
has been that he's transferred
an enormous amount of wealth uh from
lower income and working-class americans
to
the top ten percent in the top one
percent uh
the most important thing that he did was
pass a massive tax cut in 2017.
that benefited the wealthiest americans
for example
tesla founder elon musk added 132
billion dollars to his wealth over the
past 12 months
from 2017 2019 the stock market boomed
and unemployment fell then
came the pandemic and an uncoordinated
federal and state response that led to
business shutdowns and mass unemployment
in my opinion we've seen a massive
failure at all levels of government
sabrina johnson is a freelance personal
trainer in los
angeles as the coronavirus took hold
gyms closed and she became
unemployed and nearly became homeless
there came a time it had been a few
months
i still hadn't received my unemployment
i was i had burned through
almost all my savings at that point just
kind of like
paying the bills and
paying for food and i got to a point
where my bank account was
damn near empty meanwhile right and then
i see the disinfectant
where it knocks it out in a minute one
minute
and is there a way we can do something
like that
by injection trump's rejection of
scientific expertise his refusal to come
up with a coherent nationwide strategy
and his politicization of mask wearing
helped make the us the worst affected
country in the world
in the u.s we have approximately
25 26 million workers who've been
hard hit it's a huge share of the labor
force over 15 percent of workers are
suffering today directly
as a result of the corona recession
compare that with japan
where a covet 19 public education
campaign and widespread mask wearing
helped prevent major shutdowns as of
late december fewer than 80
thousand japanese workers had become
unemployed amidst the pandemic
trump leaves an economy in ruins one
that will take
years to repair rob reynolds al jazeera
los angeles